need motivation or chisel 10 with Belize
nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so get ready to get some
discipline step outside your comfort
zone and stop lying to yourself with
jakka willing and my take on his top 50
rules of success volume 2 to give you
the belief that you need okay let's
think it off with rule number 1 get
discipline let's say you're the most
ultra motivated guy in the world when
that alarm clock goes off there's at
least 50% of the time where you just
that that soft little pillow is just
caressing your head and you want to stay
there and it takes discipline to go nope
I'm gonna get up out of this bed I'm
gonna do what I'm supposed to do and
that discipline that you have at that
moment you win that fight that's a big
victory and then that that that pattern
will carry out throughout the day
because once you're up well now that I'm
up I might as well go work out because
I'm already up and I I feel good that I
got up out of bed and I won that battle
let me go win another battle I'm gonna
go get it done and then when you show up
at the office and there's someone that's
got a big box of doughnuts that they're
given away for free by the way so
they're just sitting it's almost like an
insult not to take them but when you've
already gotten up early you had the
disciplinary you already worked out you
had the discipline there and now you see
the box of doughnuts you're like no I'm
not gonna eat the doughnuts no no
doughnuts you're not gonna do it and
that discipline carries on throughout
the day so now you take that and you you
expand that out over a week in a month
and you end up with more discipline and
it starts with that simple act of
getting up and getting out of bed in the
morning we all want freedom right we all
want to have freedom we want we want to
have financial freedom we want to have
more free time we don't have physical
freedom that's what we want
everyone wants freedom of course but if
you want to have freedom in your life
the way to get to freedom is is through
discipline it's that's how you get there
so if you want to be if you want to be
financially free you
to have financial discipline you have to
save your money you have to work hard to
earn more money you have to not buy by
stupid things that you don't actually
need right you need to save that money
and invest it properly if all that takes
discipline and if you have that kind of
discipline you'll end up with more
freedom if you want to be if you wanna
have more free time everybody wants more
free time but if you want more free time
how are you gonna get it you have to
have more discipline time management
rule number two step out of your comfort
zone I'm a chef in a large operation
kitchen recently during my last review I
was given some advice by my boss and his
boss they said it was important for me
to give up some of my kitchen dog
mentality and work to showcase my
artistic side and embrace more of a star
role in the spotlight get out of the
kitchen a bit more gain more exposure
specifically with our high-profile
clients should I heed their advice or
stick to what I do best and keep getting
after it on my terms just funny how how
that last statement is framed right I
stick to what I do best and keep getting
after it as if to say if you say no you
should not stick to what you do best
it's like you should not get after it
right that's that's the frame there and
actually this guy I answered the
question real tersely I think this came
through Facebook messages so you know I
said sounds like you found a comfortable
little zone for yourself and you want to
stay in there right cold-blooded
response and he's like I knew it because
as we know in the comfort zone ders
there's no growth in the confidence good
if you really don't want to do it well
then you can keep being the guy that's
in the back and guess what you're gonna
be mad in six months when some other
chef gets hired for a different shift
and all of a sudden he's out making
friends with everyone he gets promoted
and why does he get promoted well look
what the guys doing but he's not as good
as he's not as good as a cook as I am
guess what they don't really care hmm
being making the food is only part of
what they
you to do just like being a seal doing
doing missions is only part of what they
what you need to do to do the mission
yeah you can't just be tactically sound
you've got to have the relationship
though so you can work in the
battlespace that's owned by a
conventional commander you got to have
the relationship that you can get your
missions approved up the chain of
command on a Special Operations side how
do you do that you build you go out you
talk to people you get out of your
comfort zone rule number three stop
lying to yourself we lie to ourselves we
don't tell ourselves the way things
really are and when we do that then we
can't fix our problems if we can't fix
our problems we're not going to improve
so we have to be truthful to ourselves I
have to be truthful to myself you have
to be truthful to yourself you have to
stop rationalizing stop making excuses
stop telling yourself little water down
assessments of where you're really at
tell yourself the truth so that you can
get where you want to go you can be who
you want to be you could be who you
should be who you should be when you do
what you know you should do when you pay
attention to the little things when you
implement discipline true and
unflinching and unmitigated discipline
in your life when you stop when you stop
trying to find a sweat list solution
when you look for weaknesses to work on
when you allow no easy excuses and all
that starts when you stop lying to
yourself then you stop lying to yourself
that's when you can become who you know
you should be when you tell yourself the
truth about where you are so you can
make sure you are in the right place and
if you're not in the right place then
you can get yourself on the path to get
there
half of discipline the path of hardwork
and the path of truth rule number four
talk last say more I have been somewhat
of a pushover for the majority of my
life since listening to the podcast I've
been trying to assert myself more one
thing I can't seem to shake is
constantly being interrupted how can I
rise above and overcome this obstacle so
when I'm in a group of people that all
want to talk and I want to talk over
each other and they want to cut each
other off you get in that group right
there
III don't talk yeah I don't talk I let
there's I sit there I listen to him and
i plot then I think and I put together
my thoughts correctly so that when I do
decide to say something it's going to
have impact mm-hmm and then I wait for
the right moment right because if
there's people get a bickering back and
forth I wait for a lull in the fire and
when that low comes then I make my point
in a very direct manner
I might even I might even have to wait
until the conversation is like all but
over
hmm wait till they're done with their
little fire fight yep yep yep yep yep
yep yep yep yep
and then I'm gonna talk you're done and
what I when I talk you know I'm gonna do
it since I've been thinking about it's
gonna be articulated in a way that I can
present my full point and I so I think
that's an effective way to do things I
think I think if you let people speak a
bunch you let them get it out of their
system and then when you decide to talk
they don't have anything left to say so
that's a way to stop getting cut off so
this is almost like flanking right this
is flanking the fact that when people
have a bunch to say and they got all
these thoughts in their head and they
want to get them all out let them get
them out don't try and fight that battle
they've got a bunch of things they want
to say let them say it all so as we know
when you listen to someone else
talk it you you now know what their
ideas are yeah you know what they're
thinking there's a power and not saying
anything because
that allows you to think and it allows
you to hear what other people think and
it allows you to hear other people so in
a conversation you get to hear other
people's counters to what people are
saying and you're not you're not having
to expend any ammunition to yourself
someone else is doing it you know the
third or fourth or fifth piece person
the conversation that's expending
ammunition and running their mouth to
try and solve can or some point that
someone made let them do that because by
the way then you get to see what the
other counter is hmm
so I think being assertive doesn't mean
talking more I think being assertive
means talking less talking at the
appropriate times monitoring and
understanding the firefight that's
happening so that when other people have
expended their ammunition you can step
in and you can take your shots in a
simple clear concise manner here's
another thing it's like the little boy
that cried wolf right if I yeah if I
talk and talk and talk and talk and talk
I'm taking away the value of each one of
those statements that I'm in because I'm
making so many statements that not all
of them can have a high level of value
so if well who do you who do you pay
more attention to the person that makes
100 statements yeah and what are those
okay let's say you want to pay attention
the person that makes a hundred
statements how much can you pay
attention to those 100 statements how
much do you how much do you gather from
those hundred statements yeah it's it's
a limited amount yeah it's one percent
per statement right what's one person
you have to fear you think I make some
meditators at one percent per statement
if the person says one thing how much
percent do you pay attention that on
that's right you're present also if you
want to have more confidence checking my
254 series they're free the links to
join are in the description below people
want to know how to stop the laziness
and they will not estoppel crass
donation and I looked at him and I said
I'm not a brand I'm a person
self-discipline he comes from the self
it comes from you rule number five keep
things in perspective when we deployed
to Iraq in 2006 we
been fighting since 2003 and we'd had
very few casualties in the SEAL Teams
the amount of guys that had experienced
their teammates killed in action was
miniscule and so there was no
preparation other than what I had taken
away from reading about combat for my
old life what I did was what I knew how
to do which was work and that's
literally what I told my guys was we've
we've crossed a line and there's no
there's no possible way to replace or
describe or overcome the amount of just
heart wrenching sadness that you feel
when you lose a teammate I didn't know
what to do and I didn't know what to say
first time first time second time third
time irrelevant put time I think that
understanding history and reading and
knowing how people have gone through
this before just the fact that you know
when we we we had a small number of
casualties you know we lost three guys
from tasking a bruiser
each one of them is an epic loss to us
and to humanity and at the same time in
World War two in World War one there
would be days where thousands upon
thousands were killed and so that
offered me a small bit of perspective to
think to myself that human beings we can
feel like we're special and we can feel
like no one's ever been through what
I've been through and the world is hard
for me and easier for everyone else well
the reality is that's not true and we're
not special and the things that people
go through other people have gone
through most likely much much worse and
much more significant so that to me was
a it gave me at least some level of
perspective to realize that other
warriors had gone through this before
this was my turn and this is how I'm
gonna try and handle it rule number six
build relationships I'm kind of
antisocial right like if you don't know
me we're not gonna have a conversation
you know like we're not having if I'm
like it's not I'm not I'm gonna walk it
up and talking to you if I don't know
you I'm not walking up and saying hi to
you it's not happening it's not my
personality if you say hi to me I'll say
hi I'm not disrespectful I'm not rude
but I'm not looking to have a bunch of
conversations with people and so that's
known to me but that's not okay for the
business side of my life which is hey I
gotta talk to people gotta build
relationships gotta had to know my
commanding officer had to know the
Commodore had to know the the the
conventional battalion commander had to
know the brigade commander had to build
relationships could I just talk about
war with the brigade commander well I
could but what's more powerful that I
talk about war and I talk about where
I'm from or where he's from or what you
know know other things yes cuz I want to
build a relationship with why because
I'm trying to build trust what why
because I wanted to allow me to go out
there and do things in his battle space
rule number seven have goals sometimes
even if you're the most highly motivated
person in the world that grind starts to
beat you down a little bit and that's
when you have to stop looking at the
short-term thing because that's not
that's not getting you did to get it
done and you got to look okay what is
the long-term goal that I'm looking at
what am I really trying to get done in
the long term and you say oh you know
what I'm actually waking up today early
so I can be ahead of the curve so I can
sell more of these widgets or whatever
so I can buy a house and you know what
today matters today matters this
decision that I'm making right now is
that first step it's me taking one
stroke swimming in the right direction
heading towards the shore and if I don't
take this I'm not making any progress
rule number eight have balance something
I realized so as Lafe and I have been
talking about why we wrote the book the
dichotomy of leadership why we pick that
topic and what we've been saying is most
of the questions that we would get asked
would be about the dichotomy of
leadership that's completely true but
I'll tell you on top of that more
important most of the answers that I
give are that there's a dichotomy in
leadership and you need to be balanced
that is what you even today I got asked
at camp hey Jocko I'm a white belt but I
want to be default aggressive but I also
hear you tell me to relax all the time
which one is it what do you want me to
do should I be default aggressive and
get after ya or you tell me relax and I
actually you know I say relax harder
right you wanna relax for a bit which
one do you want me to do and I said well
luckily and Leif's there to him like
love luckily for this very reason later
I just wrote a book called the dichotomy
of leadership and there's a dichotomy
with aggression even though I say
default aggressive and I say you go
that's got to be your mindset that's got
to be a default Buddhist you're gonna be
aggressive but you're gonna go get after
it
and there's a chapter in the book you
that doesn't mean that you run to your
death right you have to balance that
with caution with with energy
conservation with not wasting movement
on the mat with not wasting capital in
business without burning bridges like
all those things you have to be balanced
rule number nine be open minded
obviously you were a commander on a unit
you were not a bat battalion commander
you were a commander still you have
people that are reporting to constantly
how can you differentiate between
somebody that could be a leader of your
universe is somebody that needs a lot of
hand-holding with their trends that you
saw were there certain things that you
were looking at again this is one of
those things where I mean you know you
can look at a person you can do an
assessment and I do pretty good with my
assessment you've been in business for a
long time you you do per year in the
army
you know you do pretty good with your
assessment but you're you're only baton
sixty said how many times you've hired
somebody thought was gonna knock it out
of the park and two months later you end
up firing them hey long live it's a long
list right how many times you've yeah
you know what I'll give a guy a shot and
then they end up being a great person
you know you get right some of the times
you know probably 60 70 percent of the
time maybe even more but you definitely
can't guarantee anything and that's why
I look at everyone with an open mind I
look at people an open mind so not only
do you know I want you to be humble if
you want to learn but I'm looking at you
with an open mind I'm not looking at you
putting you in a box and thinking oh he
doesn't really have this capability I'm
looking like okay let's hope he has the
capability and if he does we're gonna
build on it we're gonna turn them into
wrists into a into a solid leader rule
number ten
snooze don't press snooze snooze doesn't
help but loses one of those things that
just sees a dream killer
yeah it's like a stairs bottom turn
dreams that score that's the truth yeah
it's like a complete think it's gonna
help you dream more when it's not commit
destroy your dreams it's a psychological
trick if you produce the thing that you
think pressing the snooze helps you with
like I'll just get that extra eight
minutes to sleep that eight minutes to
sleep building to be any more energy by
the way
18 seconds there's a there's an 18
second window in the morning when your
alarm goes off that sucks
it's about 18 seconds so 18 degree alarm
goes off the Itachi's yep the next 18
seconds are like hard there that's when
you have to use maximum effort to clear
the gravitational pull of your pillow
if you can get away from those 18
seconds then you're okay you just get up
get away from the pillow it's pulling
you in yes some tractor fever I need to
get away from that and so that 18
seconds and once you're up and moving
your bit rule number 11
be strategic if I'm tired today if I
wake up in the morning it's 4:30 and I'm
like man I am wicked tired and I don't
feel like doing this today what I do is
I note it down in my head like okay you
were tired then I go do it anyways and
if I'm tired the next day if the next
day I say the same thing then I'm like
okay you know what that's two days in a
row your workout was weak I'm paying
attention and like okay guess what you
need to you need a little downtime
that's that's the way I do it I won't
accept like the one thing in the world
I'll procrastinate is procrastination
thank you if I want to take a day off
it's like okay the other thing about
this is is you know this idea of
quitting right this idea of quitting and
never quitting and and people can
confuse that because if I'm in charge or
if I'm in charge of a squad and it's
like hey we're gonna we're gonna go
assault that that bunker on the top of
the hill okay there's a bunker on top of
hill with a machine gun in it my squad
we're gonna go assault it if we charge
uphill to an elevated position I know
there's a lot of vets in here what's
gonna happen okay yeah two or three of
us get killed like that you know what we
never quit go again
two or three more guys died go again
everyone's dead did I never quit I never
quit did I fail my mission yes I did so
you have to keep track of like what's my
long-term goal my long-term goal isn't
to take that machine-gun nest
it's the win the war so if you're doing
something on a daily basis and you start
feeling casualties you need to assess
yourself and say you know you can have a
business idea and I've talked to a bunch
of people like this they got that
business idea and their mindsets I'm
never gonna quit well then they're
running out of money not just money for
their business money for their family
and it's like okay hey if you've got it
what what adjustments can you make
strategically cuz the pattern that
you're going right now if you keep
charging up that hill with that business
the way you are everyone dies if you say
you know what time for a tactical
retreat time for me to step back time
for me to call up some firepower to come
and help drop some bombs on this target
or get some fire support whatever the
case may be so keep that in mind as well
rule number 12 go on the offense
sometimes overwhelmed there's just too
many things going on and you start to
feel like you're getting beat like
you're losing the battle and when that
happens to me what I like to do is I
like to go on the hardcore offense so I
just call it a sprint I will sprint hard
I'll I'll take the things that I have to
get done for work and I will just pile
them up and I will work two or three 12
16 18 hour days to get caught up it's a
lot better for me to suffer hard for
three days and grind then to suffer the
continual burden that's weighing on your
back for months on end don't let that
happen
if you get a little bit behind and you
need to get caught up hit the turbo
button go hard for three or four days
get yourself where you need to be rule
number 13 make your life better than a
movie Anthony Bourdain obviously he was
about as successful as as anyone could
be I mean he was a successful guy in so
many aspects and yet and yet he killed
himself he said in this book I wanted
adventures I wanted to go up the null
river to the heart of darkness in
Cambodia I wanted to ride out into a
desert on Camelback sand and dunes in
every direction eat whole roasted lamb
with my fingers I wanted to kick snow
off my boo
in a mafia nightclub in Russia I wanted
to play with automatic weapons in pnom
pen recapture the past in a small boy
stur village in France step into a seedy
neon-lit boqueria in rural Mexico I
wanted to run roadblocks in the middle
of the night blowing past angry militia
with a handful of hurled marble packs
[Music]
experience fear excitement wonder I
wanted kicks the kind of melodramatic
thrills and chills I've yearned for
since childhood the kind of adventure
I'd found as a little boy in the pages
of my Tintin comic books I wanted to see
the world and I wanted the world to be
just like the movies that's what Anthony
Bourdain said just like the movies but
you know what to me the world is not
like the movies the movies aren't real
they don't exist but you do and life
this life is it's better than any movie
there is movies are supposed to provoke
emotion they're supposed to make you
feel something but I have a better idea
go out into the world and actually feel
it go feel joy and love and triumph and
rapture and ecstasy and glory go feel
those things
and you know with those feelings there
will be other feelings as well there
will be sorrow and pain and sadness and
desolation and suffering there'll be all
those feelings too but you know what
[Music]
that's okay that's okay
take both sides feel all that that's
what life is those feelings those
emotions those eyes and those lows those
are life
rule number fourteen take ownership and
as I talk about taking ownership of
things you know when I get done talking
to people
I'll get done and someone will come up
to me and they'll say hey you know I I
really liked what you said about about
ownership now if I could just get my
team to take ownership we'd be good to
go and then someone else would come up
to me and say hey hey I really liked
what you said about ownership that was
really cool man I appreciate it
and I I really hope my co-workers heard
you because if they would just take
ownership we'd be good to go and then
someone will come up to me and say hey
man I really like that whole thing about
extreme ownership and I really hope that
my boss was listening cuz if I could
just get my boss to take ownership we'd
be good to go and then I always have to
make it crystal clear to them that I'm
not talking about their team and I'm not
talking about their co-workers and I'm
not talking their boss I'm talking about
you I'm talking about you the only
person that you can actually control you
that's who has to take ownership that's
who has to step up own everything and we
will number 15 believe when I go up to
origin and I get to go in the factory
and see the people that that are working
hard and their work hard every day every
day and they put their heart and soul
into making these products that's that's
an unbelievable thing to say and it got
taken away you know that got taken away
and to be in this situation now where
we're literally able to bring it back
that actually means something we're not
taking our foot off the gas
we're gonna go harder we're gonna push
more we're going to get involved in more
it's gonna be a grind there's risk you
know what we're putting our money into
by machines that are covered in dust
because we believe and if you believe in
something you take the risk that's what
you do and that's what we're doing and
you don't want we're gonna win rule
number 16 seize your opportunities and
when I was getting ready to retire a guy
that I knew was a friend of mine he was
the CEO of a company and he said hey can
you come and talk to my executives you
know about about combat leadership and I
said you know sure I'll do it you friend
of mine so I went and did it and I don't
know what he thought I was gonna talk
about but when I got done he came up to
me and said I want you to do this for
every division that I have in my company
and I said well I'm retiring and I don't
know and he said I'll give you money and
I said how much and we worked it out and
I ended up talking to every division
that he had in his company and at one of
those divisional meetings the CEO of the
parent company was there and when I got
done you know briefing about leadership
that CEO came up to me and said hey I
want you to talk to the CEOs of all my
companies and you know he owned 45 or 50
companies and from there I went and
talked to those CEOs and the next thing
you know I I had a I had a new job you
know and I didn't get to retire like I
had planned rule number 17
leadership when I was a young I was I
enlisted in the Navy out of high school
that was the youngest guy in my first I
was the youngest and most junior guy in
my first two SEAL platoons and what I
was doing was I was looking at my
leaders and I was watching him and I was
paying attention of what they were doing
and I was paying attention to why we
liked this guy and why we wanted to
follow this guy but why we didn't like
this guy we didn't want to follow him
the biggest characteristic I notice of
that was guys that were humble we wanted
to follow guys that were arrogant we
didn't want to follow but that was one
of many many little lessons and I paid
attention to once I moved into a
leadership position I knew that all
those guys they were watching me they
were paying attention to me and I had to
think about the way that they were going
to react to what I was doing and I knew
that my job was to lead these guys and I
knew that they were taking notes and
they were monitoring and they were
testing and if I was arrogant they
weren't gonna follow me and if I thought
I knew everything they weren't gonna
follow me I'm not saying I couldn't be
confident because yeah you have to be
confident there's a balanced dichotomy
leadership right but you have to pay
attention to those around you to the
people that work for you the people that
work that you work for and you monitor
what they're doing and you process what
you would follow and what you wouldn't
and then you emulate that that's what I
did
that's what I'm most importantly still
doing today
rule number 18 be willing to do whatever
it takes I work with a lot of different
Millennials in a lot of different
industries they work hard and they get
after an ER super successful
Millennials in the military have been
doing a great job so to think that
society's gotten harder now on people I
don't really buy into that life's hard
she want to be successful you're gonna
have to work hard it's not just gonna
show up you're gonna have to dig you
have to wake up early and stay up late
it's the way it works you gotta be
willing to do things that your enemy is
not willing to do and your competitor is
not willing to do
rule number 19 get up early yes I wake
up early yes I wake up at 4:30 in the
morning guess what we got 24 hours in a
day the earlier you get up the more you
can take advantage of those hours the
more you get up before the enemy or your
competitor or actually in some cases
your family and friends the more stuff
you can get done before they all start
bothering you what you should do if you
want to start waking up early is start
waking up early you figure out what that
time is for you and then you start
waking up at that time now if you wake
up and it's earlier than you normally
wake up by the end of the day guess what
you'll be a little bit more tired and
then you can go to bed a little bit
earlier and you continue with that
pattern though until you get a good
fixated time of going to bed and waking
up the other piece of this is on the
weekends people think oh great it's the
weekend now I can sleep in negative you
don't sleep in on the weekends when you
sleep in in the weekends you know on
Saturday you sleep in until 6:30 in the
morning well now you're not tired at
night so you stay up a little bit later
and then on Sunday do you sleep in until
8:00 and by the time Monday morning
rolls around you stayed up until
midnight and now you don't feel like
waking up early so get up early and get
up early everyday and get a workout in
take care of your health I guarantee
your day will go better give it a shot
get some cool number 20 stop lying to
yourself we lie to ourselves we don't
tell ourselves the way things really are
when we do that and then we can't fix
our problems if we can't fix our
problems we'll Nakano proof so we have
to be truthful to ourselves
you have to stop rationalizing stop
making excuses stop doing yourself
little water down assessments of where
you're really at tell yourself the truth
so that you can get where you want to go
you should be when you do what you know
you should do when you pay attention to
the little things when you implement
discipline true and unflinching and
unmitigated discipline in your life when
you stop trying to find a sweat this
solution when you look for weaknesses to
work on and all that starts when you
stop lying to yourself
[Applause]
tell yourself the truth about where you
are so you can make sure you are in the
right place and if you're not in the
right place that you can get yourself on
the path to get there
discipline the path of hard work and
[Music]
rule number 21 hold the line
people ask me all the time like hey do
you ever take days off and my answer is
I take days off I don't schedule them
but days off happen why because life
happens right sick kid water heater
breaks car has a flat tire can't can't
get where I'm supposed to be boom
guess what you just bought yourself a
day a downtime now like travel day if
you got I get some flights that are
whatever they can leave here at 6:15 in
the morning from San Diego and sometimes
I had a late night for me to get up at
3:30 to get a workout in it's actually
counterproductive I'm smoking myself so
then I'll be like okay guess what you
just got a day off
it just came that being said people also
ask me what do you do when you're sick
what do you do when you're tired you
know what and this is a real simple
answer do what you can but you Rudy
you're just telling me you don't have a
chance to work out today you're in the
in the room over there doing push-ups
why do what you can you maintain that
discipline people want to sleep in on
the weekends negative-negative don't
sleep in on the weekends the weekends
when you got to hold the line the
weekends when you got to hold the line
if you sleep in on the weekend till 5:45
well then guess what at night you're all
of a sudden you have a little extra
energy so you stay up a little later so
then Sunday morning you sleep in till
6:30 now Monday rolls around that alarm
goes off at 4:30 you don't feel like
doing it and you start just downward
spiral right now
hey people look don't get me wrong all
right you got to sleep you got to sleep
sleep is very healthy it's good for you
what I am saying you don't need to get
up at 4:30 you don't need to do that
people have different schedules you got
your life going on you got to figure out
what works for you but I am absolutely
saying don't be lazy
I am absolutely saying get on up get on
a regular pattern and maintain that
pattern to the best of your ability rule
number 22 make better decisions how do
we make good decisions well number one
making correct decisions you got to
study you got to know and understand you
got to know the background
you've got to know the historical
outcomes of equivalent type decisions
that have happened in the past similar
situations and if you know the history
and you know the background then you can
use those to assess the current
situation you're in and then once you
assess the decisions that you can make
assess the possible actions that you can
take and then assess the outcomes that
those decisions will have those actions
will have and when you're doing that you
also have to assess the possibilities of
inaction so a lot of times people forget
that one they don't know they don't know
if they should do a or B what they
forget is there's also what if I don't
do either what's gonna happen sometimes
not doing either is good most where a
lot of times not doing either is bad so
you got a or B what should you do maybe
sometimes you got a pick air B sometimes
occasionally it's better not to do
anything and you wait and let the
situation develop a little bit more what
so the point of this is whatever you can
know beforehand you know you learn you
study you understand you know the
standard operating procedures you know
what variants variations have been made
on the standard operating procedures and
that's how you bill for word and you
execute rule number 23 be balanced as a
leader you have to be balanced right you
have to be balanced so let's just take
humility and ego because we're looking
for people that are humble but at the
same time you can have someone that's so
humble that they lack confidence that's
bad on the other side of that spectrum
you can have someone that's so confident
that they're overconfident their egos
big and they don't listen anyone else
where do you want to be you want to be
balanced somewhere in the middle I
talked about the fact that you need to
be articulate as a leader that's great
can you be a leader that talks so much
that people stop listening to you on the
other end of the spectrum is you are a
leader that doesn't say enough and now
the team doesn't know what direction
they're supposed to be going in so where
do you want to be you want to be
somewhere in the middle you want to be
balanced rule number 24 make your luck
make your luck you gonna make your luck
and if you will make it if you keep if
you keep putting forth the maximum
effort
that luck is gonna come you're gonna
make your luck happen you know that you
know that actually when we when we came
went asking the bruise or came home from
Iraq there was there was you know people
like all you guys got super lucky on
that deployment cuz we got a lot of
action right and there was two like
immediate thoughts behind that was
number one like hey you know first of
all we lost our bros like they're
nothing lucky about that was the first
immediate thought in my head was like
hey man like cuz because the bottom line
is SEALs want to go into combat mad and
that's just a broad statement and so
when we came home had been in a lot of
combat and killed a lot of bad guys and
people were kind of saying hey you guys
got lucky and and again the first
thought was hey man you know if this is
luck I don't want it the second thought
was just like the same thing like oh we
got lucky we didn't like cross ourselves
and to walk up and try and be the most
you know prepared we could be and then
get overseas and inform relationships
with all the conventional forces and do
good work for them and continue to you
know just get go as hard as we could the
whole time no that didn't have anything
to do with it was just luck and it kind
of fell into our lap but you know of
course just nod your head and say thanks
man appreciate it yeah good times
so luck is definitely a part of it a
little part because where was i lucky to
be in Ramadi because I could have
deployed a year later and a year later
Ramadi was pacified so is there luck
there there absolutely is so I don't
want to sound arrogant but luck is a
part it's like foot locks it's like a
heel hooks sure there are a part of the
game you're not a game changer right
we're number 25 don't make excuses what
is the difference between an excuse and
a reason hmm
kind of a good question right sure okay
and the reason it's a good question
because there's there can be legitimate
reasons why things happen yeah right and
so for instance urina in a sailing race
right in a sailboat and the mast snaps
in half now you don't win the race yeah
but I mean you didn't you know the mass
snapped mmm what can you do about that
or the weather's the horrible weather
rolls in and you can't launch your
aircraft so you can't go on your mission
well you can't control the weather so
you know like what's up how can that
that's a reason or you get really sick
so you can't compete in a competition
that's a reason you know you were sick
oh you do bad cuz you were sick and yet
it's a reason could be called you know
now you could look at the situation and
say okay if I'm gonna take ownership of
this did I properly test the mast did I
yeah let me ask you this did we have a
ground-based plan for the operation in
case the weather came in we were gonna
take vehicles instead mm-hmm right yeah
that would work if you get sick before
the competition maybe you ask yourself
were you resting properly were you
eating properly going into the
competition so you wouldn't get sick you
could address that correct yes so you
can still take ownership of things even
if the initial reaction is like olders
you can't control that well you can
influence that you could mitigate it
right now can there still be legitimate
reasons yes there can and for me the the
the difference the line between an
excuse and a reason is a reason you have
zero control over right you've zut you
just have zero control over something
happening well that's a reason I tell
you I was almost like the other day for
something
no this is borderline this is borderline
huh huh I had an appointment at 10
o'clock I left is a 20-minute Drive
mm-hmm
I left an hour
I left at well I left about 910 I left
50 minutes mm-hmm to drive 20 minutes
man it's just so gonna make it on time
yeah yeah I get on the road basically a
couple roads out of my house and the one
entry way to get on the freeway is
lockdown lockdown mm-hmm like incident
like isolate some incidents guy trying
to kill himself oh come on the bridge
shut the road down yeah so no one's
going on the highway so what is it
everyone's being channelized into
marginal what they call back side
streets yeah really towards rear outward
yeah the clock is ticking and and I made
it right I made it I was four minutes I
had four minutes to spare so instead of
it taking 20 minutes it took whatever 46
minutes took more than twice as long
that that could be you know a fairly
legitimate reason now luckily I had I
always you know I had planned that there
could be something out of my control it
might take even longer and that's why I
leave early to go to an appointment or a
situation like that so I could have also
checked the traffic prior to leaving and
taking a completely different route mmm
that would have been I blame myself so
even in that situation I'm kind of I I
was thinking the whole time what why did
you why didn't I check the traffic
before I left I knew this could have
happened
rule number 26 take ownership what's the
number-one thing you look for in a
leader well the first book was called
extreme ownership and what that means is
you're not gonna make any excuses you're
not gonna blame anyone else you're gonna
take ownership of whatever happens and
when something goes wrong instead of
pointing fingers and blaming someone
else you're gonna take ownership of that
problem
you're gonna take ownership of figuring
it all out the solution to that problem
is and you're gonna take ownership of
implementing that solution so that
is the number one thing that I'm looking
for for a leader to do is to take
ownership of the problems and again we
called that extreme ownership and it was
one of those things that was very easy
to see in a seal platoon because when
someone doesn't take ownership and
starts pointing fingers and blaming well
like for instance right now if I started
putting my finger and blaming you for
something what's your natural reaction
gonna you get defensive get upset I mean
it's not my fault this broadcast isn't
what I wanted it to be exactly exactly
and then what happens is we have a team
where you're pointing I'm pulling the
finger you you're putting the finger to
someone else so now we have no one
taking ownership of the problems and
therefore the problems never get solved
the opposite of that is when you have a
good leader that steps up and says hey
Ben you know what this broadcast didn't
go the way I wanted it to I should have
done a better job preparing - for your
questions I'm sorry I apologize and now
instead of you beating defense if you
say you know what no actually I could
have done a better job and now both of
us are taking ownership of the problems
and we're gonna get them solved if
you're blaming everyone else I can't
control you I can't control these other
things outside I can I can't control the
only thing I can control is me so
instead of worrying about who else is
causing you problems worry about what
you can do to yourself to improve your
station and if you go down that path
you're gonna find you have a lot more
control than you think you do
rule number 27 get discipline how many
people are like involved in a start-up
right now they're starting up right cool
so I'll start up is like a little kid
right it's got all this potential it's
got all this potential what happens with
a little kid that never gets disciplined
yeah little kids that don't get
disciplined turning to Satan that's what
happens
and guess what now in the beginning like
a start-up like a baby when you got a
baby you got to do everything for it in
the beginning you got to hold its head
you got to make sure everything's
perfect the way do whatever it takes to
get that thing keep that thing alive you
got to do it but once that thing starts
to expand well then you better start
imposing some discipline on it or else
that thing will turn into Satan rule
number 28 focus on the things that
matter as leaders I see people getting
caught up all the times in little things
that will not affect the outcome unless
they let it so I see some white belt
below them in the chain of commands
going all crazy grabbing their sleeve
and this leader on the top like it gets
concerned about it and puts time and
effort into something that doesn't
matter whether it's a little personality
rub a little ego uprising you took
should we do it this way or should we do
it that way it doesn't matter that's a
little sleeve grab it doesn't matter and
I see people getting caught up on things
that don't matter all the time and what
I've realized is it's something that I
figured out a long time ago I don't know
when but a long time ago I figured out
you know what that thing doesn't matter
I'm not gonna worry about it that thing
doesn't matter I'm not gonna worry about
it that thing doesn't matter I'm not
gonna worry about it that thing matters
I'm gonna focus on that thing mmm and
that makes that makes a big a big big
big difference it's its leadership
capital as if I'm investing my leaders
of capital and getting your hand off my
sleeve or trying to do it my way instead
of your way or trying to keep your ego
in check if that's what I'm investing my
leadership capitalist I have nothing
left to vest in the thing that's
actually matters rule number 29 improve
your leadership skills do you think that
it really is that leadership is is
blower's at bread yeah I get asked this
question all the time
and so it's both it's absolutely both
and you as a human being are gonna get
certain characteristics that are gonna
make you a good leader and you're gonna
lack some characteristics that would
make you a good leader if you had them
you don't get tens across the board you
know it's like the
the little videogames you see kids play
where you get a 9 in strength and a 7 in
intellect and a and an 8 in dexterity
and you get those 2 as a leader and you
don't get all tense
so some leadership characteristics that
make you a good leader for instance
obviously it's good to be articulate if
you can express your message clearly to
people that's gonna that's gonna help
you from a leadership perspective if you
have some natural charisma that's gonna
help you from a leadership perspective
if you can look at complex problems and
you can simplify them that's gonna be
helpful as a leader because that's what
you're doing
so if you're persuasive there's all
kinds of things that will help you as a
leader and you're not going to be good
at all
and so as a leader if you look at the
ones that you're weak at you can improve
them that's that's what's beneficial so
you can't take someone that's just a
horrible leader and make them into an
amazing leader but you can take someone
that's a decent leader and you can make
them into a very good or even an
exceptional leader because you know you
can definitely get more articulate you
can definitely get more comfortable
speaking to people you can definitely
get more more precise at taking very
complex problems and simplifying them so
that your team can understand what it is
that needs to get done so these are all
things that you can improve upon and I
always have to close this out by saying
that there are some people that cannot
become better leaders and the people
that cannot become better leaders are
the people that can put their ego in
check because they lack humility and
those people they think they're doing
everything great so they're not going to
improve as leaders you can't coach them
you can't convince them they think
they're perfect and they're gonna stay
where they are from a leadership
perspective rule number 30 keep grinding
the things that I'm supposed to be doing
aren't getting done no one's gonna do
them for me and that's the way it's
gonna be right now if I'm laying in bed
not only am i letting myself down I'm
letting down everybody that's on board
everybody that's in the game and I'm not
gonna let them know it's not happening
you're not able to predict
exactly what's gonna happen so what do
you do you keep grinding don't know why
things happen all always but I do know
this when the opportunities are there
you gotta go
rule number 31 fight on what do I do
when I'm broken when I'm broken I relish
it
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna use
it cuz if I'm broken then I just found
my limitations and until I know what my
limitations are how can i push them how
can I get better but once once I see it
once I feel it once I see where I was
broken then I can attack that weakness I
can fill in that gap I can reinforce
that breach if you break it means it's
time to fortify your will to make it
stronger then look there's there's all
kinds of different ways to break you can
break physically you can break mentally
you can break your heart you can break
your spirit and none of those are fun
and all of those are gonna leave a mark
but the mark that they leave can be the
mark of victory or it can be the mark of
defeat
cuz every time you break in in every way
that you break wow it's a chance it's
definitely a chance for you to give up
and for you to just to fall apart but
there's also opportunity there's
opportunity to get stronger and get
smarter and get faster and get tougher
and get more stable and get more
resilient and get better in fact if you
break the fight is just beginning and as
you are all up and out of that dismal
and wretched place covered and you're
offered in blood and sweat and dirt and
filth as you rise above what you were
and as you take the form of of who you
are supposed to be you will see that in
the very act of standing up in the very
act of fighting on you will become and
you will remain unbroken rule number 32
focus on the things that matter you can
put so much working above so much focus
on working that you lose track of your
family
yeah and everything goes down tail with
your family or you can do the opposite
put so much focus on your family that
you lose track of that you don't do what
you're supposed to do at work so you
need to back off a little and you get
people that waste time on things that
don't matter
mmm this goes back to remember the
podcast we did where I was talking about
how like a black belt when a white belts
grabbing grabbing a black belt sleeve
and it just doesn't matter there's
people that think that it's important
that I do this thing this certain way
and the reality is it's useless it
doesn't matter you
OCD right you're being OCD so or you
maybe not being full OC but you're being
borderline you've got to think about
what's important what's not important
and if your discipline if you generally
or oftentimes people that are hyper
disciplined about little things a lot of
times they're missing their discipline
in other areas of their life and one of
them and and you we've talked about this
before too which is somebody that just
because someone is hyper disciplined in
their physical fitness doesn't mean that
they're disciplined in their rest of
their life in many other ways whether
it's financial whether it's their
relationships whatever like everything
they can be screwing every they're super
disciplined in weighing their food and
doing macro calorie counting and all
that stuff right and yet they haven't
paid their phone bill or whatever and
they've got financial issues or they've
got health like other health issues and
so you need that you need to back off
enough on the little things that don't
matter that so that the things that
matter you can actually take care of
real number 33 learn from mistakes I had
the opportunity to go to fight to flight
school but instead tested positive on a
drug test and I was given a general
discharge I of course take full
responsibility and feel like an idiot
how would you recommend moving past this
failure well my seal career had ended
with a mistake I would have figured out
what my next mission was going to be
that's that's what I would have done I
mean I would have said okay I like that
job I failed at it what can I learn from
that and what can I do next
differently to make sure I don't make
that mistake again I'm gonna learn from
the past but I'm not gonna dwell on it
mmm
there's no point in dwelling on it the
only point in dwelling on just to learn
from it so that's what I would do here
and then I would take what I learned
from my experiences of where I failed
and I would also take the positive
things that I learned because you even
that even that failure is a positive
even that failures are positive because
you realize you realize the value
of the opportunity that you had and you
blew it and you're like okay I'm never
to let that happen to get a lesson
learned I'm actually stoked I get to
learn that lesson because it's gonna be
more opportunities that come up in life
and you got to make sure that you don't
disregard those opportunities when they
come up and so I would have taken those
lessons learned take that take that
failure and turn it into something
positive and made good things happen
when I figure out what my new mission a
new career was gonna be rule number 34
just do more when you you've crushed
your daily to-do list do you then take
the time to relax or do you tack the
next day's list is that against
prioritize and execute since the mission
is done for the day you know just do
more just keep going even if it's
something I keep going do more if you
have extra time do whatever you can do
to stay ahead and I do that pretty much
until I'm brain dead and I can
definitely work myself into until I'm
brain dead like I can get to a point
where I'm reading or I'm writing it's
just it's just it's just done I'm done
and so I just have to stop and take a
break and then I'll go do something
mindless for a while you know so you
know if you if you got stuff to do keep
hammering until you can't hammer anymore
and then say okay you know what I need a
little breather and then take a little
breather and then get back to it
rule number 35 make a change people that
are quit drinking and quit doing drugs
and quit losing their temper and I've
heard from so many different people that
have implemented change in their lives
so so many letters and messages and
notes and I want you to know that these
people aren't a bunch of of elite
Special Operations warriors that's not
who they are they aren't a bunch of
high-level athletes or highly screened
in highly trained individuals these are
just just normal people really but
they're normal people that knew they
needed to make a change and they decided
they were going to make a change and
then they made it and that is what I do
and that is what you in do too if you
have something to change if you want to
change something change it change it now
we're number 36 be a good leader so what
you have to be do what you have to do is
don't be offensive when you take
ownership when you take ownership you
can't be offensive when you take
ownership some people get offended by
that
so when you say hey you know what this
is mine I got this that bothers some
people when you say you know what this
is my fault now I'm gonna fix it that
even that offend some people what the
tone just a tone of like no this is my
fault I got this mmm you do that three
day three times four times five times is
awesome because Oh what everything's his
fault not he's gotta fix everything they
he doesn't think I can fix it right
you can offend people with with all
kinds of stuff you have to work very
hard to offend people I mean there's
people get offended when you say
something nice to him even when you're
taking ownership people can actually be
offended by that if you go too far so
instead of old firt lee stepping up and
taking ownership in this particular
guest and you can tell but what's going
on here my brother here young warehouse
manager he's fired up he wants to make
things happen he wants to get after it
and so what does he do he's like oh I
read extreme ownership I'm gonna take
ownership of everything and that's a
great attitude to have
except for you can offend people when
you go too far because you got to read
the second book that I got a feeling so
that you could you can balance that out
a little bit so instead of saying like
hey this is mine I'm gonna take
ownership of this and make it happen
instead you you know you look and
someone you say hey you know what do you
want me to take care of this oh hey you
know what that's probably in my
department you want me to take care of
that so that way get away or like hey
seems like this should be something I
should take care of you want me to
handle that instead of me me me me
rule number 37 be well I'm a 17 year old
I'm a blue belt in jujitsu which I
received a few days after my 16th
birthday
and I have ambitions of pursuing
jiu-jitsu professionally and competing
to the highest level possible of course
this requires discipline and commitment
I miss parties and social events in
order to Strange Jitsu and wait train
because I know that I should have the
discipline to do so however I feel
lonely and isolated because of it is
this just weakness or should I make the
occasional exception for a social event
if you can't like communicate with
people effectively that's a real problem
in any environment mmm right if you're
isolating yourself from other people and
you're not you're not learning how to
interact with other human beings in a
social environment that's not good and
it's not only it's not only that it's
it's not only that it's just not good
for you because yes you as a person you
need to be well-rounded you need to be
yes you need to be strong you need to be
capable from a fighting perspective but
you also need to be smart you need to be
articulate you need to be quick-witted
and those things are mandatory skills in
life I mean if you're a black belt in
jujitsu and you're a white belt in
communicating with other human beings
that's not going to be a good situation
for you and the other thing is the
better you are the more well-rounded you
are in all these other aspects life
those things will actually make you
better at Jiu Jitsu too because you'll
be able to read people you'll be able to
deal with confrontation you'll be able
to understand other people's motivations
and all those things come from
interacting with other human beings
so I get it I get the massive commitment
and that is what it takes like if you
want to pop compete at the highest level
I'm telling you yes you have to live
breathe and eat jiu-jitsu you have to
live breathe and eat conditioning and
that being said if that's all you live
breathing eat that's gonna make you less
apt
to be a champion then if you make
yourself a little bit more well-rounded
in some of these other aspects room
number 38 question leadership a soldier
should always question their leaders not
just their leaders values but their
leaders plans their leader strategies
their leaders vision you should question
everything that your leader is telling
you and if you see something is wrong
then you should raise your hand and call
it out and I would say not only is it
something that you should do it's
actually your duty it's actually your
duty is to raise your hand as a soldier
and I'll tell you this doesn't only
apply to the military it applies to any
organization and it might sound like I'm
encouraging mutiny or rebellion but
actually the opposite is true if you
have a team that questions the leader
the leader doesn't become weaker the
leader becomes stronger if he's a good
leader if he's on the right path if he's
doing the right thing he becomes
stronger because everyone starts to
understand why things are happening they
understand the vision more fully if the
leader doesn't have a good vision and
he's getting questioned and he can't
answer the questions yeah he might have
a mutiny on his hands but it's not
because the people are last questions
because he doesn't know what he's doing
rule number 39 get discipline on one
lesson do you wish you'd have learned
earlier in life that you now know this
freedom I mean that is the thing that
that when I connected that together in
my head that the fact that that applies
to absolutely everything that's the
biggest lesson that I wish I would have
learned earlier in life and if I would
have figured that out then I would have
been doing a lot better and I would have
done a lot better I would have been a
lot better of a person kids in mind this
is something that I completely missed as
a kid the actions that you take now
affect your future
that sounds so obvious but when you're
14 you just think no nothing I you know
my life is only another 20
so what I'm doing right now doesn't
really matter so when I talk to kids I
try and explain to them the discipline
goals freedom and then I try to explain
to them that what you're doing right now
really will have an impact to where you
are in the future and I don't know if
you listen to that podcast that I do it
the warrior kid podcast that I did at
number 19 about my friend Jeff and I
talked about it on the adult podcast as
well but you know it's a classic story I
had a best friend when I was little and
we separated friendship not we were
still friends but we we drifted apart he
started getting into party and getting
into drugs and all that and I didn't and
his trajectory in life just went down
and I joined the Navy which was great
and it put me on a good path or almost
involuntarily
but he ended up he ended up killing
himself and you know he was drugs it was
alcohol and it was just bad but while I
was going through buds he killed himself
and what I tried to explain to the kids
on the warrior kid podcast is like the
decisions that the little decisions that
you make
they matter they add up rule number 40
learn to deal with stress if you want to
learn to deal with stress put yourself
in stressful situations that are under
some kind of control you know even
something like paintball you know we do
gigs and echelon front when we put
people through what we call ft X's where
you go out and you're gonna fire we
usually use airsoft because it's a
little bit more it's a little easier to
work with but actually what we started
using now is we've got things high-end
laser tag guns and so that's that's what
we use and they are super effective
they're they're they're awesome they're
awesome training tools like if we would
have had him if we would have if they
would have existed when I was in the
SEAL Teams I would have used them that
because they're that good so we use
those and we put people in stressful
situations go hit this target there's
bad guys you know people are gonna get
shot there's people yelling put yourself
in stress with stressful situations and
learn to detach put yourself in
stressful situations with the purpose of
learning to detach and stepping back
mentally to figure out what's going on
renumber 41
don't trade days for dollars I struggle
with the daily grind trading days for
dollars but you help me make it happen
yeah and my comment was like okay well
thank you I guess
because I hope at the same time that
you're grinding that you're trading that
your I hope that you're not trading days
for dollars long term because long term
that's a losing proposition right if
you're grinding and it's not doing
something you want to do if it's a grind
that you can't embrace then you gotta
find a way out of that right you gotta
find you can't tray you don't want to
trade days for dollars because dollars
don't mean anything days all you got so
you got to find a way out now this does
not mean you need to be rash about it
this doesn't mean tomorrow you walk you
know blow through this job anymore I'm
out and now you're broke no don't be
rash and don't throw the baby out with
the bathwater but do come up with a
long-term plan about what you want to do
how you want to do it where you want to
do it and this might take one year or
two years or five years it might take
five years to get to where you want to
be that's okay that's fine it's it's
actually kind of cool when you're
grinding right now cuz you know there's
something that you're working towards in
the long run that's actually awesome so
but but you gotta have an exit strategy
you gotta have an exit strategy you've
got a plan and figure out how much money
it's gonna take and what are you gonna
do you're gonna work two jobs I'm gonna
save all my money right now I'm gonna
invest here you pay off my mortgage
whatever is you're gonna do so that you
can get yourself into a position where
you actually enjoy doing what you're
doing that's what you want
rule number four you to know how to play
the game if I tell you echo hey echo I
want you to do this mission I want you
to do this way take your platoon and go
do it and you disagree with what I'm
telling you mmm and you just say hey
boss I don't want to do it that way and
I said hey you shut up and do what I
told you to do and you go you know what
you can fire me but I'm not doing it I
go okay
fine you're fired and I get knucklehead
over here who's a yes-man it comes in
and I tell him to go to the mission
where I tell him to do it and he goes
and doesn't gets everyone killed mm-hmm
would it have been better off if you
said okay boss I get it I I'll do it
your way here's some things I'd really
like to not do and you go no I said no
shut up and then you take your guys you
mitigate everything that you can
actually there's an example of this in
Band of Brothers where major winners is
being told hey send a reconnaissance
element across the river again tonight
mm-hmm and he doesn't want to do it the
the war's almost over they had taken
some casualties I think the night before
when they did the same type of operation
and he just says got it boss and then
the guys go and they sit in a they
pretend to go out but they really just
sit in the basement of a building on
their side of the river mm-hm and then
later on they say yup we went we came
back we didn't find anything okay cool
there's a perfect example hmm
imagine if major winners winners was
like we're not doing it and now you get
in an ego contest with the colonel was
like oh yes you are no we're not okay
fine you're fired
let me get knucklehead over here yeah it
was gonna do what I told him to do who's
a total yes-man and now we take that
risk and guys get killed so so who is it
Bella there's a coiners played the game
he played the game so he could still
have that influence and power and and
still protect his guys yeah you can get
complex yeah it's it's very that's why
the leadership is hard yes it's it's
weird though because when you say it's
complex and you say leadership is hard
at the same time like you if you're a
principled human being and you have
principles and you know what's right and
you're doing the right thing for the
right reason the decisions are actually
usually a little easier
clearly clearer yeah it might not be
easy but they're clearer like I know
what I'm supposed to do here yeah I got
it yeah I got I'm gonna figure this one
out
rule number 43 work with others and it's
easy to justify yourself you know like
you're you're let's say okay I'm real
good at fitness you know my biggest guru
and I go around and then I see out I
know I go to the store go to some party
and I see this other guy who's like
socially he's just a hundred percent
everyone likes me such a nice
charismatic guy
makes a lot of money you know and all
this stuff but he's not in that good of
shape or I don't know he smokes and
whatever you know it's ease I think a
lot of people it feels like it's easy to
justify well that guys in bad shape so
who cares I really want any of that
I wouldn't want all the money you know
all this stuff it seems like and you
know if the other guys saying yeah you
might be in good shape guess what yeah
nice Toyota Corolla you're driving he's
all negative on it yeah yeah yeah so
both those guys should Ishould instead
of saying hey you know what they should
do walk up and be like hey man you know
what I noticed you're pretty successful
financially I would like to get in the
game with you a little bit and and learn
from you about that any other guy should
say to him well you know what it looks
like you're in pretty good fitness
levels I would like to get in the game
with that let's work together and
improve ourselves and go out and kick
ass and dominate are you in I'm in let's
do this instead what does a normal
person do they do exactly what you say
justify criticize cut people down
instead of building them up yeah and
what you have to be careful of if I was
to go to you and say hey you know echo I
got a lot of money I can tell you don't
have a lot I'll help you out that's that
can be offensive to some people yeah did
you think do you think you are no need
your worry about money yeah think I'm
worried about money when I got abs like
geez you know so what we have to do is
instead of if you if I came to you and
said echo dude I want abs like you got
sir can you help me get in the game and
then we form a little relationship and
now I say to you man so yeah what you
were what's your main income stream dude
you know what are you doing and you say
well you know I got these two clients
you got a website no not really
well why don't you have a website you
got any social media to advertise all
you know and we go though that road and
we hold up we take care of each other
cause we want to do as people yeah kind
of like you ever seen the guys who go
they see like a football player or
something I mean like I'd kick his ass
though you know you know that King guy
get always like some success see now
he's a stuff yeah
yeah then well I've told the story
before the SEAL Teams it's oh no no one
is good although if a guy like we have
guys in the SEAL Teams that are
literally you know world-class athletes
in whatever world-class triathlete
world-class sailor world-class whatever
and so oh you owe your your world cost
triathlete oh yeah that guy's really
good triathlete that's cool he's a
really bad job
someone's gonna chime in and cut him
down yep rule number 44 control your
emotions there are many times in life in
the world where showing your emotions
are gonna have a negative impact on your
situation you're you you give up the
takedown
jujitsu competition mm-hmm and you show
it in your face
that person just thinks I just proved
you right you don't show any emotion
their boss tells you getting stuck with
the underperforming team show any
emotion right don't don't oh man
mm don't do that hey what about this
there's a good one boss is giving you
feedback that you don't agree with roll
your eyes I mean the the heavy sigh the
clenched teeth as you're trying to
listen with this person you don't even
respect him he's telling you what's that
gonna get you not gonna get you anything
then showing that negative emotion there
you need to keep normal face in that
situation your kids doing something
that's annoying it's try to test your
patience and they're just trying to piss
you off
don't let them keep it in check get told
to go to the other line in DMV after
you've been waitin for an hour one don't
freak out don't show any motions got it
yeah here's here's another one we
already talked about this one
your friends are poking front of you
because you missed a shot at the range
or you got lost on a land navigation
course or whatever look get all mad
don't get frustrated
don't show any emotion you know they
make fun of your haircut they make fun
of your accent they make fun or whatever
don't show emotions don't
freak out that's the other balance now
there are also times where you might
have to force yourself to show some
emotion just to get the point across
right your kid hasn't listened to you
after five or six violations hmm
you might have to show some anger or
they'd or they do something that's gonna
get him hurt right you've got to show
some emotion so that they realize that
was real but flying off to temper and
aloof lying off the handle and losing
your tempers it almost never does you
any good so yeah you have to be balanced
in order to be balanced you have to be
in control and in order being control
you have to detach from your emotion so
you can control your emotions and not
let your emotions control you rule
number 45 have a clear purpose how
important is purpose reason or cause in
being successful clearly purpose and
reason and cause are extremely important
this is this is the why of your actions
this is knowing why you're doing what
you're doing this is the commander's
intent and so you you absolutely that
absolutely is are important if you don't
know why you're doing something well
then let me ask you a question
why are you doing something it's it's
it's very clear it's very simple to
understand so yeah you got to know if
you don't know why you're doing
something then what were you gonna do
when you hit an obstacle you're gonna
stop what do you what what adaptations
are you gonna make when things go wrong
to overcome them you're not gonna make
any cuz you don't know why you're doing
it yeah so if you have no reason if you
have no reason for doing something
you're not gonna do it
so you gotta have a long-term goal we've
got to understand the underlying purpose
of what you're doing
rule number 46 be a good leader you know
who you have control over you you know
if control you don't have control over
your nine year old kid you might think
you do but you don't you got to make
enough control over your wife to just
make her you know get in the game mmm oh
you wanna do you wanna stay on the
program you want to cook whatever 14
chicken breasts on a Sunday night so you
got to a day during the week honey make
it happen
no honey don't make that happen
if you are a good leader and you explain
what your goals are and you get her on
board with the program hmm then yeah
guess what she's doing on Sunday night
helping you cook some chicken breasts
for the week yeah but this is just like
anything else Ben this is just like any
other leadership situation you want to
blame the team when something's going
wrong that's not gonna get you a
solution you need to take ownership of
the problem you need to get the problem
solved and when I say get the problem
solved you
this doesn't mean impose your will on
the team that means you need to leave
the team and there's a big difference
rule number 47 don't put all your eggs
in one basket don't put a hundred
percent of your effort into one area
because eventually it will take you you
won't have anything else and by the way
if you put all your you know if you put
all your all your eggs in the basket of
intellectual power now you're unhealthy
and you die right that doesn't you know
I don't care how smart you are you can't
do two plus two when you're dead so
don't put all your focus a hundred
percent into one area don't become
unbalanced in your disciplines you
spread it around and hold the line rule
number 48 surround yourself with high
achievers what's the best approach to
managing people that outperform you yeah
I think this is a simple question as
well what you do in this situation is
you give them all the support you can
and let them run I'm happy if someone's
outperform me that's great you know what
else I'll do try and learn from them and
see what they're doing
try and spread the word if I'm gonna
leadership position and someone's doing
outperforming everyone great how can we
take that how can we teach it to
everyone else how can I give them
support so they can run even faster this
is no factory to me I love it
you should be surrounding the more
people you can bring on your team that
help perform you the better you're gonna
do rule number 49 learn how to hire good
people everybody wants to know who to
hire and what I look for and obviously I
look for someone that's humble
and I look for someone that's balanced
and really you know it's one of those
things where as much as you can before
you hire someone get to know them and
the advice we give people on front all
the time when they're looking a hire
someone is we say look if you can hire
them temporarily bring them on as a
contractor for 90 days you have to see
them in the environment that they're
actually going into they're gonna be
working in before you know what they're
really gonna be like because just like
going through they screen people like
crazy to go into seal training and it
they can't tell who's gonna make it
who's not gonna make it they just can't
tell and they you work with people in
the SEAL Teams and you think you know
what they're gonna be like when you're
going to combat but you just can't tell
you can have a decent idea but you just
can't tell and so if you get the
opportunity or the best way to do it is
try and bring people on board in a
temporary manner so you get to know them
better and then once you know them you
can either hire them or you can get rid
of them easily and rule number 50 the
last time you for a very special bonus
clip is have a back-up plan when I
retired from the Navy and got out and
started the consulting business working
and one of my risk-averse friends that
was staying in the military for it's
it's welfare program write it so it's a
paycheck right and he the guy wasn't you
know he wasn't all fired up anymore but
he was in and so you had a mortgage to
pay and kids to feed so he's just
staying in and he kind of looked at me
when I was getting out and I said yeah
man I got bills to pay too but I'm gonna
go and get after it somehow and he said
what are you gonna do of it if it you
know if the business doesn't work and
you end up you know you're gonna come
back in and about what are you gonna do
you won't be able to get back in ba ba
ba ba and I said bro worst case scenario
everything goes to hell guess what I'm
gonna be doing I have an RV I will be in
my RV with my family we'll be driving up
and down the coast of California raiding
jujitsu schools and training and I'll be
surfing it's all good and it won't cost
me barely anything do that my retirement
Oh cover we'll be good to go you got a
back-up plan like that that attitude for
me freed me yeah Oh worst case scenario
I lose everything cool I still have my
RV it's paid for yeah
yeah we're good yeah totally now I have
a special bonus clip from Jocko and how
to build self-discipline that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one what's the biggest
lesson you've learned from a past
mistake number two where do you need to
be more disciplined and number three
where are you lying to yourself now if
you like this video you're gonna take
some immediate action
give me a hash tag believe down in the
comments below
where does discipline come from pretty
simple a pretty obvious
discipline comes from within
it's an eighth internal force
now sure of course you could have
discipline imposed on you by some person
like like a drill instructor
like that self-help
b-but the reality is that type of
discipline isn't the real type of
discipline that we're talking about that
discipline isn't as strong it won't
survive
what you need is self discipline our
self discipline comes from the self it
comes from you it comes from when you
make a decision to be disciplined
when you make a decision to be better
when you make a decision to do more and
to be more self-discipline coz when you
decide that you're gonna make a mark on
the world and if you think
that you're not disappoint or you can't
be dissin it's because you haven't yet
decided to be disciplined it's because
you haven't needed that discipline yet
[Music]
so make
make that completely discipline the huge
quality that will improve every aspect
of your life
[Music]
stronger and smarter and faster
and most
it'll make you free if you want more
Jocko willing check out the first top
fifty rules video I made on him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
don't plan anymore don't contemplate
anymore don't make any more excuses I
recommend that you go to bed earlier